(audience clapping)
- Everyone knows you as number 24,
which happens to be my
lucky number, so whatever.
But, I know you as the guy
who took Brandy to prom.
I mean, how did that happen?
That's amazing.
- I just saw her and asked her.
- [Kelly] She was Moesha back then.
- She was, yeah, she was Moesha.
You know, I'm just a high school kid,
but I needed a date, so.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience clamoring)
Look at y'all!
You showed up to prom with Moesha!
- Yeah, yeah.
Damn, I didn't have hair
by choice back then.
(laughing)
- That's all right, it's
working, it's working.
Let's go back even further though.
Tell us about this.
Yeah!
(Kobe laughing)
Get it, get it!
You don't care!
I don't care, look at me!
(audience cheering)
Yeah, body roll.
Oh, you went off stage,
you went off stage!
- You know.
- You exited, you danced and you exited.
- Back then, MC Hammer
was like, the thing,
he was doing the snake, the typewriter.
- [Kelly] I know the typewriter.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
- Yes yes.
- It was like the running
man was the real running man.
It wasn't like this little
running man, people doing now.
And yeah, I was energetic,
I was passionate.
- [Kelly] What was that school?
Was that a school talent show?
- Yeah, it was a school
talent show in Italy,
and my sister was a part of
it, and an act dropped out,
and so she asked me if I would do it,
and big sister kinda was like,
hey listen, you're doin' it.
And so, I did it.
- Oh, so you all are close.
- [Kobe] Yeah, yeah.
- That's cool.
- So, I did that show.
- When do you think my
children will be close?
When do you think that's gonna happen?
All my children, we got
four, and they're all like
(mouth trilling)
- Yeah, well you know how it is.
It just happens, and
then as they get older,
I think they get a little closer.
It hasn't quite happened for us yet.
- [Kelly] Me neither.
- They're close, but they're not.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They love each other,
but don't necessarily tell each other.
- A battle, it's like Game of Thrones.
Which one's gonna be the ultimate.
- Who's gonna sit on the iron throne.
- Yes!
It's crazy.
- Yeah, and ours is 16, we got 16, 13,
two soon to be three, and one
that just turned four months.
- Whoa.
You're tired.
Four months?
- Listen, I'm okay.
- Or, she's tired.
(Kelly laughing)
- She's like, finally you're
home, you get a chance
to do something, versus like being away.
- We have four too, but
yours are all girls.
- All girls.
- That's a lot of estrogen, like you went
from hangin' out with all dudes
to just rockin' with women.
- Pretty much.
- Yeah, that's a lot.
- It's all right, I just
leave the remote where it is.
(laughing)
I'm not fightin' that battle.
- You just know.
- No, no, they just come down
stairs, change the channel.
I'm just like.
(laughing)
- All we watch is animated stuff, so yeah.
- Yeah, so you probably
watch a lot of Moana.
- Dude, I saw you singing
Moana on Carpool Kara--
I was singing along with you.
- That too, dude, you
got, well, how did I do?
- You did great!
- Yeah?
I thought it was so sweet too.
And, to see a grown man, like,
my husband sings to my children.
- You kind of have to though.
If you're changing them
on a changing table,
and you see 'em start kinda go.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Real quick.
- [Kelly] Gotta make it happen.
♪ I've been staring at the edge ♪
(audience cheering)
And, they're like, they start smiling.
- [Kelly] They lot you know.
- Yeah, and all of a sudden I go from,
I turn from Black Mamba
to the white mamba.
- To white mamba!
(laughing)
- Yeah, I can sing now.
- That's your other alter-ego, actually,
that's what we found, okay.
When you're coaching your daughter's team,
which I think is amazing that you do that.
Do people, are you Black
Mamba or are you Dad?
- I'm a combination of both.
- Okay, 'cause you are a
Virgo, so I know you gotta be
a little controlling about the situation.
- [Kobe] Yeah,
perfectionist, perfectionist.
But, what I found is
it's really fun to teach
all the girls, like,
they're very passionate
about the game, they're
very curious about the game.
So, I try to teach 'em the
finite details of the game.
For example, we do things
sometimes in, by the way,
this is my little Taurus right here.
- [Audience] Aw.
- [Kobe] Yeah, it's real
sweet now until, uh-oh.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Get it Taurus!
- Yeah, you're right, get off of me.
Yeah, she's a little aggressive.
- We are, Taurus' are.
- A little bit.
- Yep.
This is the future.
(laughing)
- Yeah, hey.
- You're welcome.
- My wife's a Taurus too, and so like.
- Oh my gosh, she's crazy
too then, she's awesome.
I love being a Taurus, I
did ask my nanny though,
and my assistant, because I don't know,
all being sportsball, but
my nanny and assistant
are crazy when it comes to sports,
they know more than any man around me.
It's crazy.
So, sportsball fans everywhere wanna know.
- All right.
- There are a lot of
high-profile duos this year,
besides LeBron and Anthony
Davis, who are you most excited
to see play together?
- Okay, um.
- So, are there duos that
stick out or something
on different teams?
- Yeah, there's dynamic duos.
- Dynamic duos.
The ambiguously gay duo,
do you remember that?
(laughing)
From SNL?
Literally, that's where my brain went!
- Okay, I got a Taurus at home right here.
- What two people do you
think stand out though?
Which ones are you excited about seeing?
- So, there's another duo in LA,
Kawhi Leonard and Paul
George that are really tough.
- Yeah?
- Really really tough.
And then, there's one in Houston,
James Harden and Russell Westbrook.
- [Kelly] I'm going to Texas.
- These are all phenomenal,
like, if you watch them play
they're all insane.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, yeah, really talented.
- I do get into sports when I'm at a game.
I really enjoy it.
I don't like watching it
on TV, I like being there.
- You know what?
I kinda don't like watching on TV either.
- Yeah, it's not fun.
- It's real long.
- Oh, there's so much stuff
I could be doing at my house.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm like, if I'm at the game,
you would think I am a
die-hard, I'm like, yes!
And I have no idea what's happening.
- You're at home and you're like.
- Yeah, I would much
rather do anything else.
So, tell me about, you're an author,
so tell me about your new book.
- Yeah, so we have a book coming out
called Epoca: The Tree of Ecrof.
It's about a young girl and a young boy
who grow up on opposite
sides of the spectrum.
One's a princess, other one
grows up in the streets,
and they go to a very
prestigious sports academy,
and at that sports academy
some evil crap happened,
and they gotta figure
out how to save the day.
So, even though it's a sports book,
it's really not much to do with sport.
In a sense that sport is
just a metaphor for life.
So, when you feel anxiety,
when you feel nervousness,
when you have to learn
how to communicate better
with others, we have a way
of manifesting that magically
into the sport itself,
so kids have a visual
of how to learn about
emotional intelligence
and how to develop that
through the journey
of the characters, and so
that's what we try to do.
- Wow, I love it.
It sounds deep.
- [Kobe] Yeah, it is.
(audience clapping)
- It sounds so deep for, I love that.
- We gotta do that for our kids though.
Our kids keep gettin' content
that's very superficial.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And also, wanna have stories out there
that teach my daughters, like,
it's okay to have ambition.
And, the thing that always drives me crazy
is that every story with
a female protagonist
feels like you need to have
a romantic counterpart.
I'm like.
- We don't need that.
(audience members laughing)
- No, no no.
Like, she loves tennis, she loves track,
she loves basketball, that's it, you know?
(audience clapping)
Maybe that's just the father in me.
- You're like, so get away from our girls!
- That's exactly right,
that's exactly right.
I don't want them to date, so I'm like,
yeah yeah, there's romantic, you know.
(audience laughing)
- It is true though, it's like that.
Well, so you don't have enough jobs.
You also have a podcast for kids.
- [Kobe] I do, I do.
- You are so awesome.
- [Kobe] No.
- I thought I had a
lot of things going on.
I've met my match.
Tell us about the podcast for kids.
- It's a fun podcast called The Punies.
And that was inspired by,
if you guys have ever seen
the movie The Sandlot?
- Yes!
Oh gosh, forever.
- [Kobe] It's inspired by The Sandlot.
Come on, man, Sandlot's a classic.
We watch it every 4th of July as a family,
we sit around with burgers, hot dogs,
and we watch The Sandlot.
- That's such a good film.
- And one year, I was
watching it, I was like,
man, we need something like that again.
And so, that's when I
created the podcast show
called The Punies, which
is just about a bunch
of neighborhood kids
that play sports together
and learn from each other.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, very valuable
lessons through sports.
We don't have coaches in the podcast.
There aren't parents in the podcast,
it's literally the kids ribbing each other
and joking with each other.
- [Kelly] Like Sandlot, yeah.
- Like, Sandlot.
- [Kelly] That is so clever.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Dang, all right.